it's that time of the year again when
you head to the shops to buy presents
for family and friends or maybe like the
57% of Europeans who bought something
online in 2017 you've decided to buy
gifts over the Internet this year ah the
perfect present for uncle Eric in
Stockholm but wait why can't you buy it
oh it's a Spanish Website denial of
access to goods and services online
because of your location is called Jia
blocking and as of the 3rd of December
new rules ending the practice are
applicable imagine being in Belgium
you want to buy blue jeans from a
Romanian website you are being
redirected to your Belgium website
because in Romania they are cheaper now
you will not be redirected anymore for
your own use you can buy those jeans
from cheaper websites in different
countries and nobody will prohibit you
to do so Chea blocking is not the only
form of online discrimination covered by
the rules not accepting credit cards
from other EU countries are not being
able to register on a website based on
where you live will also come to an end
and the legislation applies to a wide
range of goods and services such as
domestic appliances online services like
web domain hosting and entertainment
tickets for concerts or theme parks so
this Christmas wherever you live you'll
no longer have any excuses for not
finding the perfect present for that
special someone
[Music]